New York is one of the few places
you can get around without a car.
The subways, they're crummy and
they're dangerous. You get pushed,
you get shoved sometimes you get mugged
in this subway during the daylight!
I can remember when public transportation was
one of the prides of New York. What's happened??
The bad thing about New York is the pressure.
You're always under pressure because everyone else
seems to be. New York is almost broke and you know
why because too much money is going to the suburbs
they're killing us. What I like about driving a
cab is you get to meet all sorts of people. You
know like I had an ambassador from the UN this
morning and screen actors. What I don't like
about the job are the kooks and there are more
of them all the time. I've been held up twice
but this is where the money is and as long as you
gotta make a living that's where you gotta be.